the arguments came down to what's more
dangerous impeach donald trump again and
risk further dividing the country
or allow him to remain in office even if
it's just for a few days
he is capable of starting a civil
war he must be impeached he must be
stopped
now on this vote the final vote was 232
to 197 in favor of impeachment
and took place in what a week ago was a
crime scene
that's when a pro-trump mob occupied
congress
in an effort to overturn the
presidential election
leading to five deaths democrats argued
this was the shattering of trump's glass
house of lies
built upon four years of racist
fear-mongering
every one of us in this room right now
could have died as senator lindsey
graham said
the mob could have blown the building up
they could have killed us all
and now the far right is calling for
return engagement
from january 17th to january 20th
they're asking the president
to pardon the conspirators in last
week's rampage
as they prepare for a race war
republicans defending the president
called the rioters a lunatic fringe
rejecting the claim that trump had
incited them during a speech moments
earlier
it was wrong to set such a
confrontational tone in a politically
tense situation
but what did he actually say
his exact words were quote
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
unquote that's impeachable
but trump also called upon the crowd to
march on the capitol to fight for him
then silently watched the riot unfold
despite pleas to intervene
only later recording a message telling
the crowd to go home
but that he loved them we love you
you're very special
a year ago trump was impeached with no
republican support
this time 10 republicans joined
democrats in the vote to impeach
last week there was a domestic threat at
the door of the capitol
and he did nothing to stop it that is
why with a heavy heart
and clear resolve i will vote yes
on these articles of impeachment
[Applause]
a few hours later house speaker nancy
pelosi signed the impeachment article
today in a bipartisan way the house
demonstrated that no one is above the
law
not even the president of the united
states
that donald trump is a clear and present
danger to
our country and that once again
we honored our oath of office to protect
and defend the constitution
of the united states in a late video
message from the oval
office trump did not address his second
impeachment
and instead asked the country for unity
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose by our actions
to rise above the rancor and find common
ground and
shared purpose today i am calling on all
americans to overcome the passions of
the moment
and join together as one american people
trump's message will not stop this
impeachment though from heading to the
senate for
trial mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader says
that will not happen though until after
trump leaves office
on january 20th mcconnell is among the
senate republicans who've indicated
they may be open to convicting trump
with the potential consequence
of barring him from returning to office
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington